[Music]
pastor mark the question is do i need to
go to church
well
the bible teaches this you know it's an
interesting question do i need to go to
church my question is has the holy
spirit placed in your heart the desire
to go to church
what is church church is a community of
believers where we meet together to
nourish one another to support one
another to encourage one another we come
each week we listen to the
singing it inspires our hearts
we listen to the prayers and our prayers
ascend to heaven with those that are
praying for the platform we listen to
the word of god in its life
transformational now let me give you two
bible texts that may help you on this
we grow in community christian faith is
meant to be done in community
and here
in the book of leviticus
the bible puts it this way
it talks about
the sabbath in leviticus 23 verse 3.
six days shall the work be done but the
seventh day is a sabbath of solemn rest
a holy convocation now what's a
convocation a convocation is gathering
together so from ancient times all
through the old testament god's people
gathered together we find that as well
in the new testament in acts the second
chapter the bible says they met they
shared they broke bread together they
they ate together they studied the word
together they sang together that's the
new testament model
what about the last days of verse
history hebrews the 10th chapter the
25th verse
it puts it this way
it says
let us consider one another in order to
stir up love and good works that's verse
not forsaking
notice this not forsaking
the assembly of ourselves together as
some is
but encouraging one another and so much
more as you see the day approaching
so paul says
as the coming of christ draws near
we will need to gain strength from one
another
courage from one another so put these
facts together old testament they met
together to encourage strengthen one
another listen to the word of god
new testament they met and encouraged
one another listen to the word of god in
before the end time he says don't
forsake the gathering of yourselves
together
if you are not attending church on a
consistent basis and you can now there
are some people that say well you know
i'm ill i can't do it that's that's a
whole different world there are some
physical liabilities that keep us from
attending church but if you can attend
church and you're not
you are missing a spiritual blessing
you're missing an opportunity to grow in
christ you're missing to have developed
friendships and relationships they're
going to make a difference for you for
all eternity so i would encourage you
find a sabbath-keeping church and attend